we keep seeing new and different sides
of you each week how have you grown as
an artist and how do you want to see
yourself grow from here um I think I
mean my confidence has gotten a lot
better I think throughout the season
however I think it's still important to
be very humble but I also think I've
kind of established myself you know who
I want to be and what kind of music I
want to sing and it's nice to know
America's receptive to that and the
judges appreciate that too and you know
it's nice to know I don't have to play
mainstream music and I still get voted
through that's that's what's really cool
and yeah last question for you I know
you guys are all close but who do you
consider your competition to beat at
this point if you're really talking
about winning this thing who are you
like that person really kills it every
week and I've got to look out I mean to
be completely honest this week everyone
was my competition I mean there's not
one person in this next group is even I
mean the more the numbers cut down it's
like you have to beat everybody I mean
cuz everybody's on that everybody in the
top five has been on their a-game since
the first audition and so I mean you
know all you can do is go out there and
do your best and hope that America votes
you through and if they don't and they
don't but uh you know we're going on
tour no matter what
you